so during my interview on yesterday's
show with
coleman hughes this topic of fixing
policing came up and we talked about a
couple of different ideas related to
that and one of the things that i had
mentioned was focusing in a little bit
on traffic enforcement as a sort of
proxy to fighting
a lot of what's wrong with policing in
the united states and i got a bunch of
emails about it from people saying
how would that what would that look like
can you talk about that a little more
so let's let's do that today now as a
pretext to this
i don't have any misconception that
dealing with
traffic laws is the solution to every
problem with policing in the united
states it's not
dealing with traffic enforcement
wouldn't do anything about lack of
training or improper training or the
wrong training
it wouldn't address qualified immunity
if that's something we want to look at
it wouldn't
you know deal with funding or a whole
bunch of other things but there's a
reason why
traffic enforcement is arguably some of
the lowest hanging fruit that we should
look at right away when it comes to
policing which is that
traffic enforcement is number one an
area where police are allowed
a lot of discretion and inherent bias
manifests when there is discretion and
number two traffic enforcement and
traffic related
uh infractions are the primary way in
which
americans interact with police by number
of incidents every single year and so
what what i mean by this is
when it comes to traffic enforcement
we're all familiar with situations
in which i get pulled over and you get
pulled over
and are told we were driving 12 miles an
hour over the speed limit in other words
the pretext for the stop is exactly the
same
but there might be very different
outcomes based on the discretion of the
officer so
i might end up with a speeding ticket
and points on my
insurance paying a higher insurance rate
for several years
i might get my car searched because the
officer
believes that they smell alcohol in my
car when they pull me over
meanwhile you might get pulled over
doing the same
alleged 12 miles an hour over the speed
limit and you get a verbal warning and
have a nice day and the repercussions of
the discretion that is applied
by officers to the same scenario
can be dramatically different even when
the facts are essentially just
the same and this could be just a result
of the bias of the police officer
officers have a lot of discretion in
terms of who they pull over
when they see somebody run a stop sign
for example
once they pull them over who do they
question more aggressively
whose vehicles are they more interested
in searching
who do they have step out of the vehicle
for a field sobriety test when a car
drives by with a tail light out
that discretion can be the difference
between an interaction that leads to a
police shooting
or ultimately an arrest versus someone
who just
drives home not even realizing that they
drove by a police officer with their
taillight
taillight out so because traffic
enforcement is the most common way that
people come into contact with police
every year year in and year out
and it can serve as a sort of blank
slate from which investigations can
start
we should be looking at this very
closely so what are some ways
to reduce the discretion which can be
influenced by bias
when it comes to traffic enforcement one
idea
is to replace some traffic enforcement
with
automation whenever possible by that we
we mostly mean
cameras because of course that is a way
to eliminate
a bias from an individual officer now
you can still choose to put the cameras
in certain neighborhoods and not in
others
and you may have people who are of a
certain economic class
who can better lobby to prevent the
cameras from coming into their
neighborhoods and push the cameras
into poor neighborhoods or black
neighborhoods or whatever the case may
be
but it's something to look at you can
have situations you know on highways
it's typical that on highways people
everybody's driving over the speed limit
then you need to figure out if you're
going to replace highway
speed traps with cameras well how much
speeding is acceptable there are some
complexities there but at least in some
cases
automating elements of traffic
enforcement
would dramatically reduce interactions
with police and it would therefore
reduce the number of interactions that
become
problematic replacing traffic
enforcement
and speed traps with police cameras
would limit
the bias of an officer in leading to
discretion being used in a
discriminatory way
for example now it's not a replacement
for fixing all of the other things that
are broken certainly
but it would be significant nonetheless
so then there's the idea
of having someone other than armed
police
handle some traffic enforcement we've
talked about
homelessness mental illness do we really
need armed police handling
calls to 9-1-1 related to homelessness
it's probably better suited to some
other kind of professional
if we can't have better trained officers
trained like social
workers for example maybe
there would be some other type of
professional that would be better
suited here something analogous could be
you know
for certain types of traffic infractions
you would have something other than an
armed police officer now the devil is in
the details of course
and it's true that while the vast
majority of traffic infractions
don't escalate in any way and the ones
that do sometimes escalate because of
the officer
there can be traffic infractions where
someone knows that they have a warrant
and it can lead to erratic behavior
there's a lot of guns floating around
there so
you've got you've got to think it
through right there's this is not an
obvious and easy
solution but it's something to to look
at but the point is and this is why i
feel strongly about it
when 20 million motorists per year
are pulled over according to the
stanford policing project and these
interactions traffic related
interactions
open the door to such a huge amount of
discretion on the part of the officer
it's an area of low-hanging fruit where
finding some aspects to automate
finding other areas better suited for a
different type of professional than an
armed police officer
we could make a lot of progress there
while i don't want to
ignore this while we look at dealing
with
training qualified immunity lack of a
bad actors database at the federal level
all of the different things that we've
been talking about
let me know your thoughts does this seem
like an avenue that should be pursued
what do you see as the obstacles what do
you see as the possible
shortcomings of it that maybe i'm
ignoring let me know what you think
speaking of police it's spreading from
portland
i almost would say like a virus plane
clothes
police officers threw a protester
into an unmarked van in new york city
yesterday
the video is being widely shared on
social media
millions and millions upon millions of
views and once again
we get to this question of what is the
line between
legal policing by undercover officers
with undercover cars
versus the authoritarian suppression of
protesters
appearing to be denied due process now
the police department
says this is a simple arrest a woman was
allegedly damaging police cameras
police came in arrested her open and
shut
it's all very very simple now it is true
that nypd will often use unmarked
vehicles when they're looking for people
with warrants the idea is
you want to show up in something that's
not obviously a police car if you have a
dangerous suspected criminal they may
act erratically or try to flee if they
see a police car so you show up with
some kind of unmarked vehicle now
the counter in this particular case from
legal advocates and from other groups is
that this is the worst
possible time to be using these unmarked
vans and that this was not someone
police had been looking for for a long
time who had prior warrants
this was something that supposedly
happened during these protests
alleged damage to police cameras and
thus
using these unmarked warrant squad vans
is completely out of scope unless you're
trying to send a message
and intimidate now there are about four
five different issues here the first
issue
is the growing use of these squads that
drive up to a protest
guys run out with guns and throw someone
into the van
you may not even know whether these are
police or whether you're being kidnapped
and then they drive away
extremely dystopian extremely disturbing
and concerning
there's the bigger discussion about
reforming police we had a number of
segments about that
this week already we had another one 10
minutes ago and we're going to continue
talking about that
then there's the political utility of
the repression of protests for donald
trump and we can't ignore that
and we can discuss these things
separately nypd policy
federal troops versus local law
enforcement we can have all these
discussions separately but
under underneath all of this there's
this idea that a desperate cornered
trump
wants to foment chaos incite more
incidents to then justify
more deployment of militarized troops to
create more chaos
and more unrest to justify needing
an authoritarian president to protect
you from the chaos that you yourself
caused and fomented
there's this vicious circle feedback
loop and while here we're talking about
nypd rather than
federal paramilitaries that have been
dispatched the strategic implications
and the implications politically are are
very very similar
but there's another issue that we have
to talk about one of the
things that's coming up in these
incidents with unmarked vans
is people resisting arrest now resisting
arrest is an
old trope i've been telling you for
years that resisting arrest can be
a very pernicious catch-all that's used
to justify using more force against
people
to retroactively justify police
interactions where it
doesn't even make sense because you can
only start to resist arrest
after an an interaction has started
using resisting arrest as a
justification after the fact doesn't
make any sense
but it's extra relevant right now there
are many
normal reasonable people who if you're
at a protest and an unmarked police
vehicle drives up
i'm already using the wrong terms you
don't know that it's a police vehicle
if a vehicle dries up that has no
indication of being a police vehicle
and dudes without law enforcement
uniforms
jump out and go after you you don't yet
have any reason to believe that that's
the police
you could genuinely think you're about
to be kidnapped by random people
so then you try to get away or at least
delay being taken
until you can figure out what's going on
now you're resisting arrest
and that's used to justify being
manhandled and even more force used
against you
it's a joke i mean it's it's truly a
dystopian joke
the people defending this or at least
looking the other way
and saying well it sort of kind of makes
sense if the woman was suspected of
destroying cameras
you've lost the plot how does it become
the norm
that this is how you're taken away for
the alleged crime
of damaging a camera okay
this is not some major violent
individual even allegedly
it's not someone uh wanted for beating
their wife or
what you know whatever imagine whatever
violent crime you want to met you know
raping someone you're suspected
of damaging a camera and we're now
saying it's an
acceptable response for an unmarked van
to drive up
as if they're looking for whoever slam
on its brakes
six guys run out and throw you into the
van
now i hope it doesn't happen but imagine
that if one of these out of uniform
officers
in an unmarked van gets killed because
someone believes they're getting
kidnapped then what well then
it will become a catalyst for even more
repression of protests you can be sure
of that
but this is very ugly for four
five six different reasons and because
it is so useful politically
this you know even though these weren't
federal troops this still serves trump's
political motivation which is we're for
law and order he keeps tweeting every 12
hours trump tweets law and order
it still foments the idea that we need
uh armed and aggressive police to keep
order in cities and it's useful for
donald trump either way so let me know
what you think is my analysis missing
something important here um am i
overstating
the concerning nature of this let me
know i'm on twitter
and remember that you can get the daily
audio podcast
every day weekdays we take weekends off
on whatever
your favorite podcast platform is itunes
stitcher spotify pandora
uh you choose but we are on all of them
and we'll take a quick break and be back
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day sarah
eamond and
amber lee viggers thanks to both of you
for supporting the david pakman show
also want to say thanks to nicole kearns
nicole
is today's long time sustaining member
of the day she's been with us almost
five years
grab yourselves a membership you'll get
the daily
bonus show commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
and it just feels good that that's
really the biggest membership benefit
grab a membership at joinpacman.com
so there are a whole bunch of different
interesting senate races to follow we've
been
following many of them and one of them
is horrible horrible senator
lindsey graham a republican from south
carolina lindsay's been in the senate
since 2003 he won in 2002
entered the senate in january of 2003
he's up for re-election
he has a solid challenger in democrat
jamie harrison now the latest ad from
lindsey graham's campaign
has taken jamie harrison's skin
harrison's black
and darkened it which is something we've
seen republicans do
it's a it all it they it never gets
lightened somehow
it's every time we see one of these
things where a black candidate or
politician
has their skin tone modified in an ad
it's never lighter it's always darker
and indeed that's what happened here
uh this sometimes happened to barack
obama by the way you might remember so
in this ad
which we're showing our video audience a
real picture of jamie harrison on the
left
the altered picture on the right the ad
looks to tie
jamie harrison to comedian kathy griffin
i guess it's bad if kathy griffin
supports you in south carolina maybe i
don't know among republican circles
but the most notable thing is the
digital alteration of harrison's skin
tone the graham campaign says
you know this wasn't actually about
making harrison look more black it was
just we we used an effect
on the ad we used the same effect on
lindsey graham's face
in another ad i don't know exactly where
and this is a total
non-story they say meanwhile
in another totally coincidental
accident just a mistake someone made a
republican senator published an ad
where his jewish opponent's nose was
enlarged
georgia republic it sounds insane i know
georgia republican senator david perdue
has an opponent
his opponent is 33 year old john ossoff
ossoff happens to be jewish a classic
anti-semitic trope is
the big-nosed or hook-nosed jew the
purdue campaign published an ad to
facebook where john ossoff's nose i mean
can you believe this was digitally
enlarged
and by the way done not super
professionally ocef's nose
is enlarged but it also just looks weird
and adding to this the ad includes a
picture of senator chuck schumer who
also happens to be jewish
but is a senator from new york has
nothing to do with that race
and it includes the tagline democrats
are trying to
buy georgia of course playing
up anti-semitic tropes about jews and
money with the big nose and everything
the purdue campaign was confronted about
this they said oh
yeah that modification they're calling
the
enhanced nose size a modification
the modification was made without their
authorization
because of an error that a vendor they
work with
made so i guess blaming it on
whoever they hired to make the ad now
is it believable at all that a vendor
would do this
and even like without the nose
enlargement that's only slightly better
they're still
including chuck schumer for some reason
and talking about democrats
buying stuff both of the democrats
pictured
happen to be jewish it's it's very
difficult to imagine that this is an
accident
but i guess that's the way they're
playing it now as a preempt
because there are going to be p you know
every time we talk about this people
write in they say david
republicans aren't anti-semitic it's the
republicans that
support israel whether while democrats
don't or support israel to a lesser
degree
i i don't know if these are bad faith
actors or they're just ignorant
republicans love israel because they
believe israel needs to be in jewish
hands
for jesus to return okay there's a huge
evangelical christian movement that
loves israel
not because they understand and care
about
or or whatever uh thousands of years of
jewish oppression
it's because they think it'll bring
jesus back they don't actually care
about
jews as people certainly not american
jews who overwhelmingly
vote for democrats and remember israel
and american jews are two completely
separate
and different things republicans care
about the land of israel for
bogus religious reasons sometimes for
political reasons it's not
about fighting anti-semitism or anything
like it it's truly horrifying
that this is what we're dealing with
right now and all of these people need
to be removed
it's not looking great for david uh for
for us of john ossoff running against
david perdue i the polling is not great
uh the polling is not fantastic for
jamie harrison
against lindsey graham in south carolina
but let's remove
at least some of these people in
november i hope that we will
and some republicans are going down i
just don't know whether it's these two
but
fight every race do everything we can
there is now an extensive series of
disgusting but not altogether surprising
allegations that donald trump is
essentially laundering money through his
campaign
and then making potentially illegal
secret payments
including to his own family with that
campaign cash
hiding the recipients through
um organizations llc's
businesses and agencies and it turns out
that
hundreds of millions of dollars in
spending by trump's campaign
is flowing through two companies with no
disclosure
of how the money has been spent the
nonpartisan campaign legal center is now
accusing the campaign of violating
federal election
transparency rules by shielding the real
source of campaign expenditures and the
recipients now
remember that i mean what does it matter
he lies all the time but when he was
running for president
donald trump claimed that his
administration would be the most
transparent in history
as president donald trump has claimed
his administration
is the most transparent in history and
obviously that is not the case the
complaint is extremely detailed it says
payments have been masked
but made to a bunch of trump's family
members including
people like eric trump's wife lara trump
who doubles as campaign staff
conveniently
uh don jr's girlfriend kimberly gilfoyle
on the mend from coronavirus i think
also doubling his campaigns it's not
just don's girlfriend it's also a
campaign advisor
they also do a lot of their ad buys
through a company called american-made
media consultants and through a private
company owned by
none other than donald trump's former
campaign manager brad parscale
understand like the incestuous nature of
this
until he got demoted brad parscale was
running trump's campaign and directing
ad spending for trump's campaign and a
lot of the spending
was brokered and filtered through the
company
that brad parscale owns it's genius
right i mean
what a great way to line your own
pockets american-made media consultants
is a company that the trump campaign
itself controls meaning
once the payments go from the trump
campaign to american-made media
consultants
they go to whoever trump wants with no
transparency
tens of millions of dollars by the way
have been run through brad parscale's
company
and don jr's girlfriend is getting paid
uh 15
000 a month 180 grand a year for working
on the trump campaign
same thing with lara trump eric trump's
girlfriend
brad parscale has acknowledged that he's
paying them saying quote
i can pay them however i want to pay
them
now you probably can understand the way
in which this is a useful method for
funneling money to your friends and
family and of course
the legal case before the fec it's going
to be litigated for a long time
we likely won't know the outcome until
after the november election certainly i
would i would bet
but there should be no surprise
whatsoever
that they are doing this because this is
how they operate
donald trump has been doing this his
entire presidency trump has been
funneling money
through his golf clubs back into his
family's pockets understand that trump
at last count had golf 282 days so far
this uh
presidency when he overwhelmingly that's
his
at his own golf clubs when he goes to
his own golf clubs particularly when he
spends the night
secret service and white house staff all
rent rooms at his golf club
secret service rents you know dozens of
golf carts and they pay
trump's clubs for that that money of
course goes right back to
trump and to his family this is trump's
entire life this is how trump has done
business
in real estate in new york city and
around the world forever and you know
there was actually a time
where there would be consequences for
this type of thing in the united states
remember former president jimmy carter
jimmy carter's family had a peanut farm
in georgia
and jimmy carter separated himself
from the peanut farm so that he couldn't
conceivably be seen
as acting in a way that was favorable to
his family's business like imagine that
he were to push for certain
laws related to farming that could be
seen as
favoritism to his own family's business
it almost seems quaint and provincial
that that's what he did given what
donald trump is doing now
with absolutely no repercussions
whatsoever this is the type of thing
donald trump did his entire life
uh and it should come as no surprise
whatsoever that he's continuing to do it
the only question is is he going to get
another four years to do it
if you're waiting you know as i've said
before if you're waiting for trump to
end up in prison
it's not going to happen if you're
waiting for trump to be carried out you
know
let out in hand it's not going to happen
the opportunity is
we stop this and he only gets four years
he could get
another four years to do this stuff and
by the way
do his donors care like if you're a
donor and you donated a hundred bucks to
trump
and you find out 90 of it went to brad
parr scales company
and par scale kept 20 and then he gave
20 to don jr's girlfriend
and he gave 20 to eric trump's wife lara
trump like
if you donated a hundred bucks and only
10 is actually used for an ad buy
are you okay with that are you furious
or if you're presented with this do you
just deny the reality and say it's fake
news like
please if you're a trumpist in my
audience and i know i have some
um doesn't this bother you doesn't this
just
lining everybody's pockets uh bother you
or do you just not believe that this is
going on i want to hear from you
and we'll continue covering this on the
david pakman show instagram
page at david pakman show we will take a
quick break and be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
welcome back to the david pakman show
donald trump did a wild coronavirus
press briefing yesterday and
instead of covering it all in one story
i'm sort of going to chop it up because
there's actually
so much insanity that happened at
yesterday's press briefing
that i don't want to just lump it all
together in one segment so we're going
to start with one of the strangest
moments
donald trump confirmed that he's really
jealous of dr anthony fauci
and he doesn't like the fact that people
like dr
fauci but don't like trump what's
fascinating about this is
we speculated months ago that the reason
dr fauci
started being pushed to the sidelines by
donald trump
was that trump didn't like the attention
that fauci was getting that trump was
jealous this was our speculation based
on what we know about donald trump
dr fauci was well liked dr fauci was
seen as authoritative on the virus dr
fauci was seen as trustworthy trump was
not
and thus we started seeing less and less
of dr fauci check
out this insane clip where trump just
says the thing that we all suspected
take a look anybody in the world i have
a graph that i'd love to show you
perhaps you've seen it where we're up
here and the rest of the world is down
at a level
that's just a tiny fraction of what
we've done in terms of testing
so it sort of is curious a man works for
us with us very closely dr
fauci and dr burks also highly thought
of
and yet they're highly thought of but
nobody likes me it can only be my
personality that's all go ahead that's a
president
that's a 73 year old adult a wealthy
adult arguably
in the most powerful position of anybody
on planet earth
who is motivated by sort of playground
elementary school level nonsense why do
people like fouchy
but they don't like me i'm the one who
has fouchy working
for me well fouchy's a doctor and he's
trying to save lives while trump is just
sort of
not a particularly bright guy whose
priority is getting himself
reelected and this 35 second clip just
explains so much this is a trump mask
off
moment he's showing us he's dead jealous
of dr anthony fauci earlier this week we
learned i mean it's all coming together
now earlier this week we learned that
when donald trump canceled his plan to
throw out a first pitch at yankee
stadium on august 15th
there was really no such plan in other
words nothing had been scheduled trump
ended up canceling it
but there was nothing scheduled and we
learned
that trump only announced this because
he was
jealous that dr fauci was throwing out
the first pitch and when we went back
and looked at the timing
trump claimed that he was going to be
throwing out a first pitch at yankee
stadium just an hour or two before dr
fauci
actually threw out a first pitch at
yankee stadium
this triggered trump's jealousy so
strongly that he just made it up last
week i'm scheduled to throw out the
first pitch
and now he makes it very clear why is it
you know anthony fauci has such a high
approval
i have a low approval people like him
people don't like me why is that
the complaints of like a little kid he's
just jealous he's extremely jealous and
i don't know about you but
i don't want a president motivated by
jealousy
and it comes out so strongly here and
when we look back
it's so illuminating because we we have
this movement in the united states that
for years
under donald trump and even before it
goes back to john kerry actually in
in fact the feminization of
intelligent and well-spoken men in
american society
the claiming you know this alpha male
versus
beta male stuff this has gone back a
long time
and if you remember the 2004
presidential election as many in the
audience do
um george w bush versus john kerry
john kerry couched as framed as
the feminized man the less than really a
man
why well because he uh went surfing once
or or windsurfing
wakeboarding something like that because
he spoke french
because he was educated because he was a
boston guy
and the truth was it was actually george
w
bush who figured out a way to get out of
the military like
by their own standards which include the
military military service as a proxy
to manliness and being a real man so to
speak
it was john kerry who went to vietnam
while george bush
flew a plane for a little bit and ended
up bailing pretty quickly
because of his privileged position and
so we that was the first sign to me and
i'm i'm sure it goes back longer than
that
but that was the first race where i
really saw this completely backwards you
know they framed the left as feminized
not real men
even though the reality is it's they who
avoid
the stereotypically manly things like
military service
and then we saw it with barack obama you
know law
professor obama who likes music that is
less than totally masculine and all of
this other stuff
and the epitome of it is really donald
trump i mean this alpha male beta male
stuff
has exploded during donald trump and
donald trump is the epitome
sorry donald trump is the antithesis
the antithesis of what they claim makes
a manly man
trump figuring out ways to get himself
out of military service
because of his bone spurs which many
people don't really take
seriously and now once again
is it masculine to be endlessly insecure
and say why do they like him but not me
is it
masculine to um be so
fragile that you're constantly having to
attack
others and it doesn't show strength to
me um
and very very uh revealing that donald
trump really exposed
what is underlying a lot of his bizarre
behavior and has been for a long time
now that's part one of this three-part
analysis of yesterday's press briefing
then it got
even weirder when trump told a black
reporter
that he looks like michael bloomberg
let's look at that next
so we're looking at clips from trump's
coronavirus press briefing yesterday
we're doing it in short clips instead of
one big review
because i want to make sure that each of
these stories sort of gets its own
time because it was a really weird
press briefing so trump said completely
randomly
to a bloomberg to bloomberg reporter
mario parker
that he looks like michael bloomberg now
what's really odd about this is that
mario parker is black
and looks nothing like a nearly 80 year
old jewish man
named michael bloomberg take a look at
this clip bloomberg
you look like mr bloomberg go ahead
thank you mr president i think it's
a temporary extension of a supplemental
unemployment aid
if uh the deal that their hashing got in
congress isn't completed by the end of
this week
what what does anybody make of this
tells tells the
i think this is the one black guy in the
room tells the one
black guy in the room you look like
michael bloomberg why
is this what donald trump thinks counts
as some kind of joke like is this humor
of some kind
is this meant to be clever i don't even
really get
what he's going for does trump think you
know one idea i had was
does trump think this is a way to signal
that you're not racist like
you he's saying he's colorblind in a
sense you tell a black guy
he looks like a white guy i guess that
means that trump really is colorblind he
doesn't see color and he just sees
people as people
but it's crazy it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever
i was laughing someone tweeted me you
know david
this should have been a question on
trump's much famed cognitive test that
cognitive test that trump claims has 35
questions even though it has like 12
that trump says the last few questions
over very very difficult
questions that trump says neither joe
biden nor fox news host chris wallace
could successfully
uh could score as high as donald trump
did they should have put up
a picture of a black reporter and said
does this man look like michael
bloomberg and see if donald trump passes
the test
really really bizarre stuff and i don't
know if we
chalk this up to um or or
consider this a part of donald trump's
cognitive question marks is this trump
trying to be funny is this i mean
is it thinly veiled racism of some kind
like rather
i don't even understand this and i need
excuse me i need your help
actually trying to figure it out but
needless to say
the idea of bringing back these press
briefings kellyanne conway said i think
it was two weeks ago
the reason trump's approval is down is
he's no longer doing coronavirus press
briefings
and very shortly thereafter donald trump
decided to bring them back the idea
being it would help his approval
rating by next week we'll have a sense
of whether trump's approval rating
is reversing course and improving uh
what seemed clear to me
early on was these press briefings were
actually the cause of low approval
ratings and you might remember that
the press briefings were abruptly
stopped when donald trump wondered aloud
about what about injecting isopropyl
alcohol
or bleach into the body as a sort of
cleaning
for coronavirus seems to me the problem
wasn't uh that there there was an
incredible demand for press briefings
and
after the break we are going to talk
about donald trump doubling down
in his support of a doctor who believes
hydroxychloroquine works to prevent
coronavirus or to treat coronavirus
who believes that if you have sex with a
demon
it can cause gynecological issues
who believes you don't need to wear a
mask who believes that there's already a
cure
for coronavirus um and who believes that
there is a plan
i hope you're sitting down to develop a
vaccine
that will make you immune from becoming
religious
okay that's after this short break make
sure you're following
me on instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available
on our website shipping to anywhere in
the world
at davidpakman.com gear don't miss the
bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com forward slash gear
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay so let's continue with our tour of
yesterday's white house coronavirus
press briefing i already went over
parts i guess a and b or one and two
with you number one donald trump said
why do people like dr fauci but they
don't like trump
why does dr fauci have a high approval
and trump has
a low approval when fauci works for
trump trump couldn't understand it
it was really really weird uh also
yesterday and we already went over this
in the last segment
donald trump told a black reporter i
believe maybe the one black reporter in
the room
that he looks like nearly 80 year old
jewish man
michael bloomberg so that was weird in
its own
way but none of that is as crazy as what
we're now going to talk about
trump almost seems normal in those
instances compared to
what i'm going to talk about now donald
trump jr
was temporarily limited on twitter
yesterday because he shared a video of a
doctor
named stella emmanuel who spoke
in favor of hydroxychloroquine for
coronavirus
and believes having sex with demons can
cause illness
and believes there's a plan to vaccinate
americans from becoming religious
that'd be an interesting vaccine and
donald trump shared the exact same video
of stella emmanuel to his 84 million
twitter followers but later took it down
once the uh you know what started to hit
the fan
now to avoid problems ourselves i'm not
going to play the video for you
but you can find the video easily if you
want to
the same doctor stella emanuel said
you don't need to wear a mask which is
actually
dangerous disinformation she also said
that there's already a cure out there
for coronavirus
so trump was asked about her during the
press briefing this is a really good
video you're going to hear cnn reporter
caitlin collins list
some of the things that stella emanuel
said and believes
and trump doubles down check this out
and then when caitlyn collins tries to
follow up
trump triggered ends the press briefing
immediately and walks out of the room
the woman that you said is a great
doctor
in that video that you retweeted last
night said that masks don't work and
there is a cure for covid19
both of which health experts say is not
true she's also made videos saying that
doctors make medicine using dna from
aliens and that they're trying to create
a vaccine to make you immune from
becoming religious maybe
maybe it's not but i can't i can tell
you this
she was on air along with many other
doctors
they were big fans of hydroxy
chloroquine
and i thought she was very impressive in
the sense that from where she came i
don't know which country she comes from
but she said that she's had tremendous
success with hundreds of different
patients
and i thought her voice was an important
voice but i know nothing about her
last week real quick thank you very much
everybody
thank you
mr president
now i'm going to admit something to you
yesterday throughout the day i sort of
heard rumblings about
don jr was limited on twitter for
sharing some video but i was busy
preparing
the show the podcast etc and then
i heard something about demon sperm
trending on twitter but i was busy
preparing for my live stream and so i
didn't really
follow the story closely you know you
hear about demon sperm i didn't know it
was related to don jr didn't pay much
attention i thought well demon sperm
must be some lightheart-hearted story
maybe it's something from a video game
who knows and then meanwhile don jr was
limited on twitter i thought maybe
there's a comedic element here there's a
meme element a joke i don't know
i didn't consider for a second that the
entire
thing could have been related to
something that donald trump
was promoting himself she believes in
demonic
sperm that can cause gynecological
problems
and that's who donald trump is saying
has a voice that should really be heard
on the issue of coronavirus and on the
issue of hydroxychloroquine
this is also intense by the way
yesterday stella emanuel tweeted out an
article written
about her in the daily beast look at
what she wrote she tweeted quote
the daily beast did a great job
summarizing
our deliverance ministry
and exp i hope you're sitting down and
exposing incubus
and succubus thank you daily beast
if you need deliverance from these
spirits
contact us deliverance ministry
one she seems to be promoting almost
like an exorcism of some kind
show us the alien dna she show us the
vaccine
that pr by the way a vaccine to prevent
people from becoming religious
would be very interesting in a number of
ways
the country may be better off if such a
vaccine actually existed on the net now
i know that i'm not saying all religion
is bad or anything like that but on the
net we might be better off with such a
vaccine
imagine a pres imagine anyone calling
this woman a highly respected doctor
whose voice is important
then realize that it's the president of
the united states who is doing it so
what i want to think about is is trump
this stupid
or does donald trump just prioritize
angering the left and remember prior to
trumpism
the three main wings of the american
right
were small government type liberty
folks you know people like in the tea
party and the the
more libertarian minded the low tax pro
business
conservatives like mitt romney as an
example who aren't
the most socially conservative people
but sometimes they are but it's really
not as much about social issues issues
as it is about low taxes and a
pro-business environment
and then the third wing would be the
religious conservatives whose priority
is you know often evangelical christians
who care the most about
abortion social issues gay marriage etc
under trumpism there's this fourth wing
and it's a wing that as i discussed
yesterday with coleman hughes
it's not really about policy it's about
angering the other side
and so is that what trump is
fundamentally doing here and cow towing
to and placating just
if the left thinks this woman's crazy
then i should defend her
and is it as simple as that uh or
does trump genuinely think that this is
somebody that should be listened to i
mean i just don't get it i don't i don't
really know what's but what what this is
all about and it's always easy to say
it's meant to be a distraction it's
meant to be a distraction from
the coronavirus death toll which spiked
over 1200 yesterday for the first time
in a while
or it's meant to be a distraction from
the fact that trump's losing every poll
or
you know you can always say it's a
distraction but i think that there's
probably some deeper
explanation or understanding that we
could have here insane
absolutely insane and i i don't have the
clip but i guess today when trump was
doing the helicopter press conference
just
as he was walking out to his chopper he
was asked again
about this dr stella emanuel and like
tripled down on it although i haven't
seen that video yet
i will take a look at it let me know
what you think explains what's going on
here
okay please allow me just the briefest
diversion
from horrible things happening the world
over and in the united states
to mention something very exciting and
positive which is that the david pakman
show youtube channel
has achieved and surpassed 900
000 subscribers in fact i think we now
are probably closer to 901
uh yeah just shy of 901 000 already this
happened
yesterday during a live stream in fact
rolling over
from 899 000 subscribers
to 900 000 youtube subscribers and so
now the race to 1 million officially
begins now about 18 months ago we were
already starting to look at you know
could we get to a million by election
day it it could happen
18 months out it's sort of hard to know
if things go well
we could maybe hit a million subscribers
before the 2020 election
we still could although we're a little
bit behind right now according to
socialblade based on recent growth
trends
we're expected to hit a million
subscribers on january 9th so that would
be before the inauguration
but about two months after the election
however
it's not impossible so rough numbers
we're 97 days from election day
and we're 99 000 subscribers short of a
million so call it you know it's like a
hundred thousand
we need about a thousand thirty new
subscribers a day
from here on out to hit a million by
election day
this actually isn't crazy the last few
weeks we've been getting 1300
a day we only need a thousand thirty a
day so we just have to hold that
and then we can do it now this is really
wild
i was looking back at old numbers you
know what the david pakman show launched
on youtube
a long time ago and we did it because
jenk yuger from the young turks who i
met in 2008 at a radio uh conference
i told him what i was doing and he said
you know you should throw some cameras
in your studio
start putting the videos on youtube it
could be big youtube could be big that's
what jenk said to me
and so we started filming the show and
it took us
five years to get our first hundred
thousand
subscribers on youtube to go from zero
to a hundred thousand
it took five years the next hundred
thousand
took only a year and five months we then
got our next hundred thousand
and only eleven months we then went from
three hundred thousand to four hundred
thousand
in eight months then things sort of
slowed down a little
it took us 10 months for the next
hundred thousand
it took us eight months to get to six
hundred thousand
took us another only four months to get
to seven hundred thousand
seven to eight hundred thousand took
seven months
and it only took us five months to go
from eight hundred thousand to nine
hundred thousand subscribers
we have just over three months
to get to a million it would be the
fastest gain
of a hundred thousand subscribers since
we've started
but let's go for it let's go for it and
by the way i also want to start hearing
ideas from people about
what to do to celebrate getting to 1
million um
send me ideas a few people wrote in and
said i should
dye my hair some color and it should be
subject to maybe people voting on what
the color would be i mean i guess i
would maybe do that my hair color
doesn't really lend itself
i'd have to probably totally bleach it
first to dry it i don't know that that's
particularly good
you know some of these chemical elements
so to speak aren't exactly the best
my guess is i'm not ruling it out but my
guess is
people can probably come up with
something more clever
than just dyeing my hair to do it one
million
youtube subscribers and meanwhile
fortunately the show is growing on other
platforms as well so i i'm not doing
like a full state of the show
address here for you today but we have
surpassed
40 000 followers on our twitch channel
which is great
the audio podcast is uh has grown like
20
per month for the last two three months
which has really given us a big big
boost
and it's extraordinary to see more
people engaging with us on that platform
so a lot of good things needless to say
send me your ideas for what to do to
celebrate one million subscribers
assuming we get there
i don't know that it's a matter of if i
think it's more a matter of when
i want it to be before election day
imagine if it was on election day
imagine if as we defeat donald trump if
we do
we surpass 1 million subscribers i'd
have to blow out memberships for two
bucks a year right i'd have to do
something
completely unprecedented if that
happened uh but send me your ideas and
we'll follow up and discuss more
okay i got a voicemail which raises a
very
relevant question i think the voicemail
number which you can call
any time of day is 219
to david excuse me david p got a little
too excited there
uh let's take a listen to this voicemail
hi
david this is jacob from denver colorado
hey quick question about your video on
trump being divorced from reality
yeah i just watched it and it makes me
wonder do you think that
trump is lying or do you think that
everybody around him
is lying to him saying hey he's winning
all of these states
he's the polls are looking great and
that these polls that
you know the public sees are actually
suppression polls or whatever it is he
calls them
so yeah i was just wondering what's your
take on that yeah this is a really good
question now there's a third possibility
here which i'm going to raise in a
moment which has actually been suggested
by some of the people around donald
trump so
when trump comes out and he says we're
winning in florida
and florida he thinks he's winning both
we're winning in
you know all these states that every
poll says he's losing in
does trump know he's lying or is someone
coming to him and saying mr president
you're actually winning in florida and
trump just repeats it
there's a third possibility which is
that trump's memory is gone and he
genuinely has no recollection of this
stuff because
some of these kind of insider tell-all
books that have been written about
donald trump
claim that advisors are shocked by how
trump's memory is gone trump will say
something one day
and then a few days later he will deny
ever having said it and we from the
outside wonder is he lying
is he gaslighting and the third
possibility of course
uh or is he being lied to the third
possibility is
he's just forgotten and i i don't know
the answer when i hear trump come out
and say
uh we have the lowest death rate in the
world
we actually have you know the ninth
highest deaths per capita on coronavirus
even our case fatality rate isn't the
low like there's no measure by which
we're the best on death rate
does trump know that that's not true and
he's lying
is someone coming to trump and telling
him that and he's the one being lied to
and he doesn't know any better
or has trump just forgotten i don't know
the answer
i genuinely have no idea which it is if
i had to venture a guess
in different instances it's
a different combination i think in some
cases trump is just lying
i think in other cases trump is probably
being shielded from less than
optimal realities by the people around
him and in some
cases trump genuinely does seem to just
forget things so i i think it's probably
a combination of the three let me know
what you think
on the bonus show today we will be
talking about we already have one
baseball team
that has bailed on the season we're days
in
because of a coronavirus outbreak we'll
talk about what we know we'll talk about
what we expect we'll talk about could
this possibly be contained now that it
is
in the major league baseball system
number two
why is there a coin shortage in the
united states not paper currency
but coins why is there a coin shortage
we will talk about that
and number three uh police agencies
are making some police agencies are
making a big deal
of saying they don't want to provide
security at the democratic national
convention
why is this happening is it political
posturing is there a bigger political
movement behind it
what forces are supporting this being
done all of these stories
and more we will be talking about today
on the david pakman show
bonus show two ways to get access to the
bonus show number one
become a member at joinpakman.com
number two become a patron at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show either one gets
you instant access
you will probably be able to join me for
a live stream later today
if you're following my training for the
upcoming pog champs ii
chess tournament uh i recently had
another lesson with international master
levi rosman we'll be posting that to
youtube soon
i also have upcoming lessons in the
works
with alexandra botez and eric rosen so
if you're looking for a break from the
politics there's plenty of non-political
content
available for you uh but of course the
streams
related to politics will continue i've
also been asked to start streaming joe
bite joe biden has started doing
press conferences i've been asked to
start streaming them i think it's
important to do so
and we're going to try to work that into
the schedule as well so much happening
and i will see you either on the bonus
show or on a live stream or tomorrow